biden's approval rating
sinks public disapproval higher than
ever before the supposed millennial
story results of a new poll released on
sunday show a further decline uh tyler
may want to pull up the poll and
president biden's approval rating
coupled with a likewise increase in his
disapproval rating the poll shows biden
now sits
at a mere 38 approval rating uh while
his disapproval rating shot up to 59
percent the poll was conducted at a
joint effort of sioux falls university
in usa today which wrote that it had
found that biden's support had centered
at cratered
among the independent voters who
delivered his margin of victory over
former president donald trump a year ago
vice president kamala harris had similar
results from recent polls she is
currently at 51 disapproval rating and
only 28 of those polled approved of the
job she's doing whoa that's very low
crushing it so um first thing that i
thought of when i was reading this is
obviously we were talking about
yesterday when we're preparing how how
reliable of polls what are this what did
that one the other so first thing i went
to was where my head went was
if
do approval ratings matter and what do
they say about the midterms if we read
here second and more importantly the
third paragraph here presidential
approving ratings in recent years have
been a decent indicator of what happens
in midterms in the last four meaning
2006 2010 2014 and 2018 the incumbent
president's disapproval rating was
higher than his approval and in all four
cases the president's party lost
a sizable block of the house seats uh
and if you scroll down a little bit more
you'll see here just kind of where their
ratings were at so obviously i think
that this is
does it matter on him and what he cares
about i think there's probably an ego
aspect of your approval rating this than
the other when you're in the office but
beyond that it's for me it's the bigger
indicator of what is the country saying
like where where were things going and
if the house flips uh in the midterm
election next year it's going to be very
challenging for him to do
anything
as hard as it has been
now when he's had all three houses molly
look at look at the change
so for clinton it was minus 52
uh parties seats change house midterms
minus 52 yeah
clinton plus five on the second term
plus eight bush minus 30 push obama
minus 63
and on obama minus 13 both times he lost
and then trump was minus 40. so trump's
the third worst between obama
and clinton and bush and clinton are the
only ones that had a positive on one of
the midterms
wow okay when does uh so bush was how
bad you think this is going to be with
bible how bad the thing with bush what
do you mean by how bad the flip
oh the house yeah or the the midterms
yes i think they're going to get crushed
like like crush like worse than obama
crushed
minus 63 like that look i couldn't see
that guy i mean he could beat a goat if
he does that i don't know about
i don't know about that but uh here
here's what i do know
um
i think
there there might be people out there
that are gonna laugh but that's fine i
think we've seen the worst
of biden
like that he just had something to make
a comeback i think he just had something
this week
that's actually going to help him
think about what's happened over the
last six months
number one has not handling covid
has not been effective the way that they
left afghanistan i think short term that
hurt him long term that might help him
long term when he if he runs for
re-election because which i don't even
know if he will uh
afghanistan was a disaster short term
everything that's happened with
inflation with the supply chain not good
obviously joe manchin chris and cinema
getting in the way the let's go brandon
thing i think a lot of the bad stuff has
happened and he's sort of weathered the
storm sort of
but
he needed a win and he just got a win
with his infrastructure bill and i've
been talking about
the need for they've been talking about
the need for an infrastructure bill for
how long
40 freaking years and in my opinion
trump really messed up when he went to
tackle obamacare and healthcare before
the um
before infrastructure but
speaking of net approval so there's a
website called 538 you're familiar with
this yeah one we're on okay is this 538
yep all right so net approval how
unpopular is joe biden net approval
currently he's
minus
nine
minus nine trump minus 18
obama plus nine
george w bush
plus 76 for whatever reason people love
george w bush plus 76
bill clinton plus three and a half
george h.w bush plus 37
ronald reagan plus 18 jimmy carter plus
24. that's over the last that's over the
last 40 years
all i'm saying is these things are
important and people didn't understand
why trump wouldn't get elected again his
net approval rating was shockingly so so
let me ask you this question one more
time do you think he's going to be the
president become the goat of the most
seats flipping uh i think he's going to
beat obama's record i don't think he's
going to beat him that's a great record
to hold by the way how many seats you
lose
catastrophic so let's talk about it
because it's about to happen will it be
more than obama will be less than no i
don't think it will be more than obama
will it be more than a a a trump
i think it will be so what do you think
the number's going to be 50 uh
45 that 40 range and a 40 range okay
what do you think do you think it's
going to be 61 63 i'm i'm thinking in
the 50 60 range okay because 60 is a
massive massive number then again by the
way you said something about afghanistan
did you see this speech
you gave like 15 years ago or 10 years
ago you got to hear what he said on the
right way to leave afghanistan okay
stop stop stop stop stop
okay stop okay
go
there's one twitter video up there
that's audio
that's very annoying up up
tyler go up
and then to the left three taps to the
left there's a bar stool video okay
kai how does it feel to be on this side
of the equation i love it i love it but
you guys got to see this thing what is
going on here kai
okay go back to while they're working on
this
you can't click i need some victory in
order to to win the crowd you talked
about winning the crowd we talked about
gladiator
by needs some victory
click on media go to the top and click
on media it's the fast
under twitter go all the way to the top
go to media right there okay
okay so then just go down keep going
down
uh until you get to the video go go go
it's gonna come up here's what biden
said about the right way to leave
afghanistan ten years ago make it bigger
about what our options are
listen
if tomorrow
the order goes out from the pres i'm
pretty united states 20 years older
today began to withdraw all american
troops it will take a year to get the
american troops out
do you hear me now that's the truth it
will take a year to get them physically
out
now if you leave all the equipment
behind
you might be able to do it in seven
months
and you leave those billions of dollars
of weapons behind i promise they're
going to be used against your grandchild
and mind someday
makes a big difference adam what do you
think about that do you agree with them
just didn't age well is what you're
saying
because but here's the thing but here's
the thing on an honest i want you to be
does he not sound presidential here he
did he did he sounds president that's
when he was running in 0-8 yeah but what
i'm trying to say is he sounds like
listen good for he made sense but so for
him to say
what he said then he did the complete
opposite leaving afghanistan
yeah and you've seen this nowhere in the
media being shared you've not seen this
anywhere in the media being shared david
harris jr shared this and then i posted
on twitter
uh and uh you know you hear a plan that
he knew what was the right thing to do
and they still didn't do what he knew
was the right thing to do just 13 years
ago i don't think he forgot about it i
just think how much do you respect joe
biden
i uh i don't think it's a respect thing
i don't think he's a number one i've
never said i don't respect a guy i don't
think he's a number one it's that simple
for me i i respect you i don't know if
you would do a better job running this
place than mario because i don't think
you would want to do that and i think
your position of strength is in a
different place just like when's the
last time you saw mario on the podcast
he almost was on for 100 when have you
seen mario on the podcast why not
why not so so think about it so this is
i'm not this isn't like i'm not a
favoritism guy i'm very much about
knowing who's going to do good here
who's going to do good there who's going
to do good here and that's not his job
biden's not meant to be there period
this ain't got nothing to do whether i
like him respect him or don't respect
him it's just not his position you don't
think he should be at the top is what
you're saying i don't think when he was
running then that's an advisor that's a
guy that you're like hey what do you
think he was a great vp i think that's
good like when he's speaking like that
he made everything he said he made sense
who would be a better number one him or
hillary clinton that's not another
question it's not hillary's number one
hillary's the number one there's no
question about it she's not not a number
one i agree with the values and
principles but you think she is she's an
absolute number one she's an absolute
number one obama's the number one
obama's trump's the number one trump's
the number one jimmy carter
not a number one no no not a number one
adam is the number one to me and
hopefully before 43 a number one for
somebody so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]